checking out a bird mount or skull or a
fish mount is just like checking out a
book
you present your library card
we scan it
it's due in two weeks and it's just like
checking out a book
this is the alaska resources library and
information services and we're in the
room that holds the furs mounts and
skulls in our collection many of the
items are available for the public
the focus of the collection
is alaskan animals birds and fish
i'd say there
are hundreds of furs
probably
50 bird mounds and hundreds of skulls
this has a walrus skull which is kind of
interesting
it's got teeth behind the tusks i didn't
realize that until i got to look at the
school it was pretty cool
the bear furs or the really popular
well bear lynx
and wolf
when people
encounter this collection they are
delighted
they ooh in awe it
sparks their imagination they
love having all the choice
of the different types of items that we
have
people who check out these items really
vary
mainly teachers for their alaska animal
component of their curriculum
i don't know of anywhere else that they
can
borrow
a mounted sandhill crane and just study
it up close
it's a very unusual program